america's getting more dangerous the
white house trying to disarm you
we spoke to second amendment advocate
colion noir
earlier on tucker carlson today about
this why
here's what i find so striking is that
at exactly the moment they're telling us
that actually you can't pick up the
phone you're not allowed to pick up the
phone and call someone for help because
we're abolishing the police
and you're karen if you call the cops
they're telling us you're not allowed to
defend yourself
that what is that
it's interesting to say the least let's
just put it like that because even
sometimes i struggle with the dynamic
because i
i don't want to believe that we honestly
have people in power
who really want to put us in a position
where we have
absolutely no means to protect ourselves
i don't want to believe that either i
agree
however what else am i supposed to
conclude from that
good question you know it's like you
tell me it's like you tell me like you
pointed out
succinctly i'mma care for calling the
cops and then that i shouldn't be doing
that or that we should defund them and
they shouldn't be there but then at the
same time you tell me
i shouldn't have a firearm to protect
myself in the event that they're not
there
so what would you have me do just be a
victim yeah
right and so at that point it begs the
question
what is the ultimate goal and i think a
lot of it
really is in the word is in the word gun
control which is
control i think the overall goal is
control
you can vehemently control a population
of people who don't have the means to
defend themselves
and we have examples of that on pretty
regularly and then one of the most
recent examples is
look what took place in hong kong when
you look at
the manner in which they try to fight
against what they consider to be their
pressure
their the potential oppressor they use
sticks
rocks umbrellas exactly
right um that dynamic i don't think will
ever play out
here in that manner because of tell me
about your hat
it says i will not comply yeah well
think about it um are we are we expected
to comply with unconstitutional laws in
this country
we're not and so what this is reference
to specifically to the idea of an
assault weapon ban
we've already had the supreme court
which decided in heller that we do have
a right to own firearms in this country
and the ar-15 is one of those it's one
of the most popular rifles in this
country
it is in common use so as a result of
that if
you're going to pass an assault weapons
ban which is in direct contrast to what
the second amendment says what our
supreme court has says
i'm not going to comply with
unconstitutional laws i'm just not going
to do that
especially when it comes to utilizing
the one gun that i think is
in the best position to protect myself
now you and i can debate back and forth
about
you know whether it's an ar whether it's
a shotgun so forth and so on right
but it is in the same vein as the
shotgun as
other firearms and other rifles as well
so why are we
trying to relegate me to something what
i consider to be lesser than with
respect to protecting my life
it's just so funny because government
policy
has caused a crime wave we've always had
crime
you know they're always people who are
going to act out in violence for
whatever reason but in the last year
you've seen crime go way up violent
crime go way up including homicides
and it's because of specific steps that
our leaders have taken they've caused
the crime and then they flipped around
and said oh look at all that crime
we need to take your guns away but we're
not going to take the guns
that are causing the crime we're going
to take the guns that are held
almost overwhelmingly with people who
cause no crime at all the ar-15 yeah
i think i think that is what i call a
slow drip
um i think the ultimate goal i don't
think i know the ultimate goal is to ban
they want to ban all the guns tucker
carlson today on fox nation this show
will be right back